ah ça me plaît pas le matin je me
regarde ça me fait pas d'avoir sonné
alors je me suis dit que si j'avais de
l'argent que je gagnerai peut-être au
loto ça peut toujours arriver et ben je
me ferai changer le nez
on peut changer son nom
esthétique j'ai le nez de ma mère et là
ça fait comme ça et puis là c'est
ma grand-mère elle me dit que ma
grand-mère a le module qu'est-ce que tu
t'es fait tu t'écrases pas
enfin je me dis des fois que quand je
vais à Marseille ou quoi je vois les
gens je regarde des gens comme ça oh là
là ça me fait la peine parce que
vraiment leur nez il est vraiment
exagéré
[Applaudissements]
si je pouvais je me l'enlever